- Have something in your life
that's more important to you than acting.
But something that's creative,
something that gives you
a goal that's all yours
and that doesn't depend on somebody
calling you up and hiring you.
So you're not sitting
around and waiting for that.
You know, write, if
you want to play a role
produce it for yourself.
Try directing, lean tap
dancing, take voice lessons,
paint pictures, do
something that is creative.
Give yourself a goal and
an aim and a project,
chances are you'll never achieve it
and the reason will be
something will hire you to act.
But in the meantime you've
got your creative juices,
you're in charge of your own creative life
and I've followed exactly
that advice my entire career
which is why I written children's books,
and last week I performed with a bunch
of mad opera singers at the Carnegie Hall.
I danced with the New York City ballet
in a ballet that I wrote myself.
You know, constantly, just make
like exciting for yourselves
that does not depend on
other people's hiring you
because the hardest thing
to live with as an actor,
the hardest thing to deal with
is being rejected by people
you have contempt for.
(audience laughing)
Find ways of avoiding
that, that's my advice.